[Music]
oh my
[Applause]
God
he
[Music]
get us out of here pull up hey pull
[Applause]
upull your grandparents they create ated
something
extraordinary and were Fearless enough
to believe that the world is so much
more vast than we could possibly imagine
what's Monarch monsters are an
inescapable reality that we must learn
to
survive you knew these things existed
this is your
legacy the world is on fire something
happened that monor didn't want us to
know about
it's a map yeah but what is it a map
oh we can do this together we can figure
it
out I'm not taking orders from Monarch
anymore time to Cowboy
Up we are looking at a wave of Titan
events threatening the lives of 7
billion people what if the three could
save the 7
billion
[Music]
w